we have one more gains talk about one
more game it's week we asked beforehand
what RK and Austin were working on there
was a bunch of rumors and and then a guy
came out wearing a very interesting
shirt Alexa haha oh my god talking about
the shirt such a good job this would
have gone over a lot of people's heads
went over my head you saw it yes so back
in 2013 kotaku leaked that arcane Austin
was working on prey 2 or whatever preto
was becoming yeah and um then I guess an
internal memo was sent around telling
people at the company in a very blunt
way yes not talk to us and Jason Trier
got a hold of the memo and a from Jason
of kotaku and published the memo on
kotaku and the memo literally said now
that they know what we're working on
like those press can I swear you can
swear those press sneak [ __ ] will be
asked will be sniffing around don't talk
to them and Ross came on stage wearing a
shirt that had a button with the word
sneak on the press sneak that's totally
broken and so funny yeah like I was
looking at a shirt I'm like what does it
mean what does it mean where does it
mean it means press dick [ __ ] so then
be like oh I guess we know what's coming
up next it is there's also pretty good
game after that story yeah sorry yeah so
they show what if what we now learn is
just called pray they're just calling it
pray it is you know seems thematically
disconnected from the original prey
which is probably we sort of assumed
anyway and it's probably a good thing I
mean yeah maybe not because like there's
there's a space station at the very
least right what else did you guys sort
of pulled for the messed-up groundhogs
day yeah yeah yeah he's got a nice
apartment i'll say that to him his
eyeball needs a little bit of work yeah
yeah it kind of reminded me I've ever
seen the television show black mirror
yes for sure everything going on here
after the rewind stop happening kind of
reminds me of something you'd see in
like a black mirror afternoon like
something freaky and kind of futuristic
unnerving supernaturally uh becomes like
a portal almost as like we have some
tests to run today yeah and then it
follows back in on itself and the stuff
that's happening at the start is is you
like this is so open for interpretation
like you can't read
from this it's obviously not gameplay
either so like who knows like we may
have situation where which they just did
the prey to thing again where this game
might be three years away and by the
time we might not see it again for quite
a while you don't mean didn't they say
something about it in terms of date or
anything I was chippy I said next year
next year is that next year yeah this is
coming out next year the thing that
let's bring it that's what I said I
think that's really interesting about is
like they mentioned it's gonna be it's
like a psychological thing right so I
feel like from what we see here it's got
a lot of influences from the modern like
psychological horror games like soma and
the other other big horror games I've
showed up on Pierre I mean if it says
the end up cornering the market on on
quake on thief with dishonored and then
they're basically making a new system
shock at this with like a scary space
thing like fair play they have just like
nailed 90 shooters to the wall in one
swoop those guys are planning work man
rice yeah that wasn't me that was an
amazing conference was great yeah I feel
satisfied same as last year I'm like I'm
like going back to my hotel room like
buzzing yeah if you guys have to pick
your favorite thing from from the
Bethesda conference first of all Michael
my Hardy Esquire what would you pick as
Skyrim special edition I got any excuse
I can get to go back and play that now
it's gonna look great it's gonna have
mods no like I said I've been doing that
on PC for a while now but this is just
an excuse to go play all these on ps4
now also our xbox one alexa ray korea
dishonored time can I fine mr. Hussein
we didn't get no Skyrim dinners but
almost no second choice only are you go
pray pray looks yeah there's something
about it that's also triggering like a
dead space thing and oh god yeah my god
I need a new dead space but if those eh
humps on willing to do it guys will take
care of me add big lotta love in the in
the chart here for prey some designer to
as well but it seems like people are
pretty happy about a happy about price
oh there you go yeah yeah
[ __ ] quake baby how would you wake us
back